夜中なんですけどもフィッシャーズの主力とんだ方が遊びに来ておりますいないような
た所みたいねまあ結構久しぶりであったわけですよ彼らに大附しぶりに会ったんです
けどもうここでちょっと僕のことをどれぐらい彼らが見ているかをちょっと検証して
いきたいと思いますこんな細かいところまで僕のことを見たことある人いないと思うん
ですけども僕の特徴として
北ローダほぼどこにもないです
[音楽]
あった基本的にほくろ中黒子は顔にもないんですけども
黒子の少ない僕を利用して今回ある検証していきたいと思います下に2人がいるんです
けども僕がここに戻ってくるために黒子を1個ずつ増やしていきますまあまあどれだけ
俺のことを彼らが見てくれてるかっていうことで黒子が何込めて彼匹ずつ
傷つきはしないですでプロ何声で彼らが気づいてくれるのかっていう現象をしていき
たいとおもいます
4行き火が出ているかニキビを隠す意味を込めって入っ
んあぁまた保護者ですん
うわぁこういう中目の者の黒子ってなんかエロイに方黒ができたのでくれていきたいと
思いますでは
指
もうすごい
rar
あああ
ネットないけどねしようぜん
数土鍋でそうねぇああああ
牛
ああああああああああああ
ああああまあは良いあるな
はぁっ
これだとわかんねーっています
ん
いやー今完全に不自然で処方左右対称みたやってますから
じゃあ2つで言っていますハーイいい
たちも怖いですよ
言われない
[音楽]
出てるのに何か出来上がっただとしてなかったら次
杉工場芽摘みコア
これ
入ったバレないなこれどうしようわかりやすく花とかに増やしておこう
ほい
どうコレこれはさせに気付くと思いますやっていきます
そう
me
行くは今一番感じのがちょい床板2
あっはぁん
これねー
持っん
too
まったくパススルーん
うーんもうるわけですよもう何か話したときはまずなさそうだからねキビやとナッツ
うち4
はむちゃんっ
これはさせる日付くでしょ戻りますはいこえー
危なくなっ
仰天行前で同型車 ok
[音楽]
うーむわーねえねえのマジへ行っ派
ana ん
ame
ああああああ
元は子ちゃん
おっ
ついてんのかなでもやっぱり近くで見ると完全におかしいのはわかるんですよ
まだ腰くらいのほくろの数なら言いますよね悪いとこれでてみましょう
うるさいん
jan
ああああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ハーフスプラトゥーンよスプラッターそうやったことだろ
1の時にローラーやって奇跡的に下手せたんですよああ
製造
voodoo
[音楽]
ben ん
ん
[音楽]
襲っそれ国力やします値ふぁいですかを分かっている決まっていく切ったけど中はきっ
関連かな人ともができパル f ばれずに増やせるか
ただ引き続き
簡単におかしいよねでも
空気もちろんさすがにあの距離なが分かりますよどんな北になるためまだバレないと
思うんでもうちょっと出ていきましょう
ん
nanaco になりますはすぎ綺麗な正三角形になっちゃったこれで行っんですって
よ
動いわー色々頑張って
ええええええ
ね周瑜が散漫だぞ
[音楽]
相手はしっかり見極めねー
ですねー
今見ますよね完全にメットメーカーがあったこのレベルで気づかないってもなにはどう
したらいいんだろう率直とに増やしてみませんでつい
なぜここで気づかなかった方もこれも同じことだと思うんですけどこれで分解いってみ
ますってよ
ran
デザートだけていざのあはい大きいも0
だなぁ三者の猫って助けな春限定発だった
ブロイラー
えええええええシャーマンねバーイ次の文はそれか選んだぜが多いが本当は追ってがぁ
あああああ姫
5あくれーじこれでわかんないっても通したと俺もうもうやばいってこれでわから
なかったらもうおかしいですからね
チーターのコスプレみたいになってますけどねこれでわからなかったらもう
東証な知ったよなぁ
よろしく御アワビじゃねーぞ voodoo
もらえるしかねーぞ
んじゃねこれで勝ちがはいけるけどそれですか分からん
そうだっ
イカー
came
me
結果は主力が込んだが64号でした
ああ
[音楽]
me
car
あっはぁ